はい 次のチャプターに入ります
それからもう今までこの感覚についてよく喋りましたから
もう一応パーリの言葉は紹介します
ウェーダナという五蘊の一つですから
我々を構成しているものの 4分の1なんです
5分の1なんです 生きるとは感覚があることです
感覚は生まれては消えてゆく流れなのです
生きているということは
物体に感覚がある それだけの話ですよ
マイクロフォンは生きていないんですよ
全然感覚がないんです
ミミズは生きている 感覚はあるんだから
アメーバも生きている
感覚はあるんだから ドキブリも生きている
感覚があるんです だから目があるかないか
耳があるかないか調べる必要ないんですよ
耳がない人は生きていないと言えないでしょうね
だからミミズには目も耳も何もないんです
しかし 感覚だけはある
だから生き物 一個の細胞であっても
ちゃんと感覚があって生きているんです
だから生きるということは
命ということは 感覚 感覚っていうのは止まらない
ずっと流れる だから結局自分っていうのはないんです
楽の感覚 苦の感覚 普通は見て楽しいものと見たくないものがあるんですね
普通と言えば普通ですけどね
聞いて楽しく感じる音といら立ちする音があるんです
舌が受け入れる味と嫌悪する味があるんです
鼻が受け入れる香りと嫌悪する匂いがあるんですね
命を守るために自然に決まっている区別です
気にしないでください
何か見ると ああ 綺麗だなと思ったりする
何か見ると やっぱりあんまり好きじゃないと思ったりする
大丈夫ですよ 例えば動物
猫よりは蛇が綺麗ですよ
清潔ですよ 何も何もないんです
しかし 人間本来は蛇は嫌いです
なぜでしょうか もう毒持ってますからね
だから毒持ってるんだから
毒持ってない蛇まで嫌いんです
それは怒りとか何とか思わなくてもいいんです
私は言うのは その自然に嫌だという気持ちは大丈夫ですよ
慈しみを持ちなさいよと
蛇に慈悲の瞑想したんだからって
蛇を取って首に巻いて必要ないんです
コブラにチューしたりとかね
そうするとコブラ興奮して噛んだら死にますからね
しかし コブラに対しても慈しみを持たなくちゃいけない
それだけの話 だから我々はあるものを見て可愛いと思っちゃうし
あるものはそうは思わない
人間は牛を飼ったんですけど
馬を飼ったんだけど シマウマは飼わない
可愛いのにね ちゃんとオシャレでいるのに
それは人間の命には何の助けにもなりません
一つはもう自由な動物だから
人間に馬鹿にされてはたまらない
決して調教することは不可能
一つ 足がまた遅いしね
シマウマといっても まあ苦労して調教することはできますけどね
でも価値が動物にはならない
その代わりに牛を 馬を飼ったりする
それは生きるために必要
それから香りの場合も
ある香りを嗅いで あ なんていい香りだなと思ったりする
例えば我々 食べる食べ物に香りがあるんです
日本は香りのある食べ物は嫌がりますけど
香りが必要なんです そこで
体がこれいい香りですよって言ってくれますよ
それ食べると体にいいんです
皆様方はこの香り解析しているんだから
森に入ったら毒キノコと食べるキノコの区別できるんです
キノコの専門家で博士でなくても
嗅いでみればわかりますよ
食べられるものか 毒が入っているのかと
細胞に毒が入っているものは
嗅いでみると ものすごく嫌だなという感じが出てくるんです
しかし この嗅覚では結果無理だからやめてください
本当に微妙にないとダメなんです
野生に森に入って 葉っぱを取って潰して
ちょっと潰して 葉っぱは潰さなくても
この指でそうやって押すと香りが出ます
それ嗅いでみたらわかるんです
食べられるものかないかって
時々果物なんかは野生にありますよ
見る限り本当に赤くて
もう肉質いっぱいあったりして
もうしかすると食べられる
でも嗅いでみたら 人間に食べられないものは人間に臭いんです
しかし 虫は食べてますよ
そういうわけで 我々には香りがあって
匂いもある 聞きたい音があって
聞きたくない音もある
それはただ この体を命を守るために自然についているもので
そこまで否定している仏教ではありません
僕はすごい科学的に そこら辺は自然法則でということで
だから虎を見たところで怖くなったっていうことは
臆病者やっていうとんでもない話ですよ
虎は猫のように見えるんだけど
猫は可愛がりますけど
虎の頭は触りたくない
自然誰も言ってなくても
虎の牙を見ただけでやべえと思っちゃう
野生で見るとものすごく怯えるんです
ですから それその嫌な気持ち
それが OK ですよ 命を守るんだからね
しかし疲れるんです 情報は振動
感覚を振動させる 情報っていうのは感覚を振動させます
前説明しましたね 同じ振動が続くと
感覚に嫌な気持ちが生じる
疲れる 苦を感じる 今言ってるのは好きな感覚の場合なんですよ
例えばいい香りが漂っている
それで気分が良くなる
そこが 30 分も 45 分も 1 時間も同じ香り漂ると疲れちゃいます
なぜかというと 嗅覚のところで同じ振動をずっと来ているんです
あの食べ物の匂いとか見ると食べたくなるでしょう
たくさん食べ物は長い時間見ていてください
1 日中 もう食欲はひとかけらもなく消えちゃいます
もう疲れるんです 長く座っていても立っていても疲れる
空腹感も満腹感も気分が悪い
同じものを見続けると目が疲れる
痛くなるということです
結局は何やっても結局やがて
苦になりますということで
ですから感覚が苦ということになるんです
今まで言った話と随分違います
話は これが仏教のもう最後の真理のところなんです
ヤンキンチウェーヴェイタン
サッバンタン ドゥッカスミンというふうにお釈迦様に説かれてます
感じるものは何かあれば
すべて苦に属するものであると
ドラマ 映画を見ても 音楽を聴いても疲れるんです
もしも感覚が楽であるならば
同じ音楽を何時間でも
何日でも 何週間でも聴き聞き続けることができるはずです
同じ曲をずっと流しちゃうと頭がイカれちゃいますよ
もし音楽を聴いて楽しいと思うならば
1日聴いても  1週間ずっと聴いていても楽しみになるはずなんですけど
そうはなりません 豆腐は美味しいと言っても
朝も食べて 昼も食べて
夜も食べて 次の日も食べてみてください
もう吐き気がします 同じものは続けませんよ
だったら 例えば 1週間一回豆腐料理を作って料理作らなくても
たまに食べる場合は もう私はもう醤油もかけませんだからね
そのままパッと食べちゃいます
しかし 毎日は食べません
で たまに食べて ああ 結構美味しいなと思っちゃいますよ
では買い物して豆腐買ってく
それはやりません 私は
なぜかというと 次に買って食べると
やっぱりお醤油かけたくなるんです
その時はお醤油の塩味で食べる羽目に
豆腐の味はもうとっくにないんです
まあ私はお醤油あまり好きじゃないんだから
ドレッシングかけて食べます
まずいと思うでしょ？やってみてください
あの豆腐に あの このごまドレッシングとかね
いろいろ体にいいドレッシングあるでしょ
野菜ですから 別に 料理番組はそこで終わって
で 見る 聞く 味わうなどなどね
感覚が痛みを感じているんです
結局は見ると痛み感じる
聞くと痛みを感じる 嗅ぐと痛みを感じる
味わうと痛みを感じる
体に触れると痛みを感じるのです
皆様方 瞑想を進んでいるならば
頭で思考が現れるたびに痛みを感じるんだよと感じるはずなんです
随分喜んで妄想しているでしょ
概念が触れるたびに痛いんです
ですから 私たちは絶えず感覚を変えているんです
そういうわけで 朝豆腐を食べたならば
昼は別なものを食べちゃう
夜はまた別なものにするんです
いつでも感覚を変えているんです
音楽好きな人はたくさんの音楽を持って聴いているんです
それ知ってるんだから IPOD
では 40 万ぐらい曲入りますでしょ
60  60 ギガバイトの IPOD の場合は
何聞くんですか？って考えたりしたんですけど
まあそう思いつつも  60 バイトの G の IPOD 買ったんですけど
買って 1日 2 日間使いました
それは今他の人に持っていかれて
もうもうないんですね
それで 1日2日音楽を聞くって
なんで 4万 4万以上でしょうにね
人に言えた立場じゃないんですけど
だから楽しいだろうと買ったんですけど
結局は苦しいんです 美しい音楽と互い違い
たくさん  美しい音楽って何でしょうかというと
互い違い たくさんの音を激しく変えながら
互い違い音をものすごく激しく変えるんですよ
これが合わせるんです
これ調整して作ることです
だからもうトランペットあるわ
ピアノがあるわ バイオリンがあるわ
それそれも合わせて もう激しい
それでなんて綺麗な音楽でいいのと
別に綺麗ってわけじゃないんです
たくさん苦が現れるだけ
苦は一色だったら苦しみで感じる
たくさんなるとどう言えばいいかとわからないんですよ
例えば ある箱に 1円玉ばっかりあると
これはお金ですと判断できるでしょ
1円玉も一つ二つある
ビー玉も四つ五つぐらいある
壊れた子供のおもちゃも一つ二つある
それで何か服も一つ ハンカチも二つ入れてあるとかね
石鹸も一つあると もうすごいカミソリもその箱にある
あの箱に何があると言えますかね
名前がなくなっちゃうんですよ
種類ありすぎちゃってラベル貼れないんです
だからそれなんです 問題は
音楽の場合はいろいろ苦を合わせているんだから
それに楽というんです
もし同じものを集めると明確にわかる
苦しいんだけど 聞くと楽しみを感じるが
聞き続けると疲れるんです
たとえ音楽 そうやって見事な音楽を作っても
一回聞くと楽しいんです
二回 三回は楽しいかも
しかし 聞き続けるともう嫌になります
それで人間思う幸福っていうのは苦しみの引っ越しなんです
歩く苦しみを座る苦しみに
空腹の苦しみを食べる苦しみに変えて幸福だという
歩いて疲れた人は座って
ああ 幸せだなという 座って腰
腰が痛くなると立って散歩をして
ああ 気分がいいという
それで歩いて疲れている人が立って
なんて気分がいいでしょう
散歩することはと その人と話し合わないでしょうに
喧嘩になるでしょうに
一人がもう歩いてもうクタクタ疲れてるんだよと
歩くことは疲れるんだよと言っている間で
ずっと座ってた人は歩くことは楽しいんだよと言っているんだから
だから苦の引っ越し 人はいつでも今の感覚を別な感覚に変えたくてイライラしているんです
どんな人でも いつでも次何とかしよう
次何とかしようと別なことをやりたいんです
やっぱりいつでも感覚を引っ越し引っ越しされたいんですよ
電車に乗っても 2時間もかかりますと言っちゃうと嫌なんですよ
そんな時間かかるのかと
同じ感覚を続けて欲しくないんです
落ち着きがなく 絶えず動くことは人間は幸福だとします
それで仏教から言えば
落ち着きがなく スーッと動く
あれもする これもするとか
これに人間が幸福だと言うんです
これは生きることで A
という苦がB という苦に変えることです
生きるということは 苦から苦へ行くことです
から苦へ引っ越しする
いつでも 服を変えることも同じことで
今日はこの服だから明日別な服にしましょうと
でもうこれが幸福な生き方だとするんです
それでもう 100着ぐらい服あった人はすごい幸せでしょ？3着しか持ってない人は不幸なやつで
もう言ってることは明らかに事実なんです
40枚 足く 40足持っていたフィリピンのマーコス夫人が幸せやと
40枚もっとかな どこであれ履くのかと思う
もう死ぬまで 1 日履いたっても終わりきらないぐらい靴を買うとかね
なぜかその女の人は最初はすごい貧乏でしたし
ものすごい貧乏で あのマーコスさんと結婚して
それから国のお金は盗みたい放題盗んで
もう無茶贅沢するという
だから日本でもなんか贅沢自慢する人はいっぱい服持ってるんだぞとかね
まだありますけど トランクにトランクルームで預かってますよとかね
毎日 1着 1着着ても 死ぬまで着ても
死ぬまでもうデザイン変わっちゃうしね
自分も年取るし もう本当にバカバカらしいんですよ
それが幸福と言って 一般の視聴者も乗るんです
わざとテレビでそういう番組流すんです
人の家の家を訪問するとか何とかというね
そういうわけで 幸福の誤解
たえず感覚が変わることは幸福だとしているんですね
感覚に楽があれば 変化に富んだ人生はいらなくなるんです
なんでそんな変化欲しいんですかね？感覚が楽だったら
苦だからなんですよ 感覚の中で幸福を探すことは誤解です
ないんです 感覚の変換が幸福なので
どんな感覚も変えたい
ですから 我々はいつでも変えたい
変えたい 変えたい 変えたいだけです
いつでも感覚を変えたい
手を動かすは 足を動かすは
左見たり 右見たり 上見たり
下を見たり ずっと感覚を変えているんです
瞑想する時は体止めてくださいよと必死で頼んでいるのに
もう日本語までわからなくなっちゃうんです
はい 体固定してくださいと言っちゃうと
わざとぐらゆらゆらゆらゆら
どれほど無知かというと
日本語までわからなくなります
時々私はこの玉木さんにもこれ日本語で言ってください
これはすごい侮辱で言うんです
ベースに私の日本語で理解できるはずですけど
それでそれ感じないんです
それで玉木さんが言ったら
あ そうですか じゃあやってみようかなと
私は一人で楽しいんです
いかに無知でアホで 苦しみのどん底で生きているのかと
で 困ることは解脱の案内できないんですよ
だから私は困るだけで
例えば医者のところに行ったら
注射しか治療方法ない
注射だけは断然断ると言うと
医者が困るんですよ 治してあげたいんだから
そういうところで困っているだけでね
でも侮辱されても気づかないんです
ということで この例えば
立っている すごく疲れる
もう嫌ですよ それで座った途端
立った苦しみが消えるんですよ
それが幸せだと感じるんです
私はみんなに出す例がありますよ
すごい空腹感がある時は苦しいでしょう
もう我慢できない そうするとご飯食べる
1口を食べるとあの空腹感が消えるんですよ
そうすると 1口ですごい幸せ感じる
1口ご飯食べてすごい幸せを感じたならば
2口食べると2倍幸せ感じるはずでしょ
3つ目食べると3倍幸せでしょ
そこで昨日ではなくて
木曜日聞いたんです ある方に
そうすると 100回ぐらい食べるとどれでしょうかと
あ 結構幸せでしょと言ったんです
物事を考えたことないみたい
笑 回はまあ普通の人間には食べられませんし
もう地獄の苦しみですよ
例えばスイカ炊き飯機 3つぐらい炊いてご飯食べたことと同じですから
だからそこでわかるでしょうに
だから問題はなんで一口食べるとすごく美味しくて
2口目からあれほど美味しくないんです
3つ目はもっと美味しさが低いんです
4つ  5つ  10回になってくると
まあいいんじゃないか
もうあんまり美味しくないってことになっているんです
その理由は何でしょうか
1口食べる前に空腹感はものすごくあったんです
それが強烈に落ちちゃうんですよ
1口で だから消した苦しみの量なんです
お腹が空いていると  1口食べても空腹感消えるんですよ
満腹になる必要ないんです
まあ例えばこのまあ欲張りことで
まあ本当に食べなくて
お腹が空いていて 何か食べようかなと思って
ものすごく食べたいんだけど
もう我慢できないと思って
ジュースとかなんとか飲んじゃうと
もう空腹が消えちゃうんです
私はそれ忘れちゃいます
空腹感ないんだから これ
あまり体にいいわけじゃないんだけど
だから満腹にならなくても空腹感は消える
ですから  1口目は消した苦しみはすごい
空腹感の 80%ぐらい消しちゃうんです
2口目は まあまた残りの５ぐらい消しちゃうと
それで10回になってくると全部消しちゃってるんです
それで11回目は消す苦しみがないんです
それで食べることは苦しいと感じ始めるんです
本当は 1口も感覚だから空なんです
あの引き算やってるんだから感じないだけ
そういうことで 食べることも本当は空なんです
空腹感も空なんです 今の感覚に十分満足しない
先はもっと幸福があると思う
これ 人間の生き方なんですよ
感覚を変えたくなる衝動が渇愛
強烈なエネルギーです
この感覚を変えたいということは
渇愛というんです タンハーというんです
これが強烈なエネルギーですよ
まあ幸福 お腹が空いたらもう渇愛はじりじり
これが無限に輪廻転生を引き起こす原因になるんです
いつでも苦しいんだから変えたいんですよ
変えたいというエネルギーはもうかなり強烈だから
なかなか消えません だから輪廻転生というものが成り立つんです